Ось якими виходять із СІЗО білоруські протестувальники.
За різними даними, під час мирних акції незгоди з перемогою Лукашенка
на виборах затримали понад 6 тисяч людей.
Частину з них під тиском європейських країн та нових акцій протесту відпустили.
Затримували всіх, били всіх: дівчат, хлопців, дітей по 15-14-13 років.
Був і чоловік - 70-річний дідусь, який з нами сидів.
Затримували всіх, навіть якщо ти вийшов з магазину подивитися - і тебе забрали.
Багатьох затриманих під час протестів досі розшукують родичі та близькі.
"Там коїться якесь пекло", - розповідають люди, які потрапили в білоруські ізолятори.
По-звірячому били людей, змушували кричати: "Ми любимо ОМОН!"
Зараз я відчуваю полегшення, що це все скінчилося.
Але я не думав, що у нас за ширмою цього спокою,
навіть близько собі не міг уявити, що коїться таке свавілля і беззаконня.
Чимало людей прийшли до ізоляторів підтримати тих, кого відпустили.
Ця дівчина не може стримати сліз після виходу із СІЗО,
розчулилася від підтримки батьків і просто незнайомих людей.
Дівчата, машина чи подзвонити - кому треба?
Щоб не потрапити в СІЗО, омоновці пропонували брутальну альтернативу.
Навіть для дівчат…
Мене запхали в автозак і сказали: або їдеш з нами на 15 діб
або відбиваємо ноги і відпускаємо.
Оскільки я стою тут, то зрозуміло, що я обрала: мені сильно відбили ноги.
У СІЗО потрапляють не лише протестувальники, а навіть спостерігачі.
Інна Дабратвор разом з іншими спостерігачами в ніч на 10 серпня
вирушила в міську адміністрацію, щоб подати скаргу на порушення під час голосування.
Але всіх їх затримали. У коментарі DW Інна розповіла,
що дві доби вона перебувала в камері, розрахованій на 6 осіб,
але там було 33 жінки - без їжі і засобів гігієни.
Поруч з нами були камери чоловічі. Там було 44 в одній і 50 в іншій.
Наскільки я зрозуміла, найбільша там камера була шестимісна.
Тобто така сама, як наша. Якщо нам 33-м було важко там знаходитися,
то що говорити про 50. Їм навіть дихати було важко.
Я думаю, що вони стояли там, як в автобусі, набитому битком.
З хлопцями поводилися дуже жорстоко, ми чули, як їх голяка ведуть коридорами до камери.
Як їх ставлять на коліна обличчям до стіни, як їх б'ють кийками.
Як на прохання викликати лікаря, їм погрожують фізичною розправою.
І постійно принижують, постійно грубо розмовляють і змішують із землею,
приказуючи: будете знати, за кого голосувати.
Акції протесту проти жорстокості силовиків у Мінську проводять білоруські жінки.
Зокрема, ця ініціативна група в білому одязі з квітами в руках.
Вони шикуються у ланцюги солідарності вздовж дороги.
Одна з учасниць Марина Шугова в інтерв’ю DW розповіла
про особливості організації акції в умовах цензури.
Коли ця акція вже відбулася, в наш чат стала додаватися величезна кількість дівчат,
усі вже додавали, мабуть, неперевірені контакти, відразу ж зламався чат.
Стали боти завантажуватися... Але щоб ви розуміли, наскільки дівчата з гумором:
чат називається "Шугарінг Депіляція", і як прийти - це запис до майстра на нігті.
Все з гумором - і це прекрасно, тому що якщо зараз не жартувати, то можна збожеволіти.
Моє життя реально змінилося на до і після.
Дівчата приходять у білому одязі. За словами Марини, цей колір для протесту
вони обрали як символ миру, чистоти і добра.
Я відчула, що, напевно, дівчата врятують Білорусь.
Жінки врятують світ і дівчата врятують Білорусь. Я не можу мовчати, не можу сидіти вдома,
не можу не діяти. Я весь час ставлю собі запитання,
мої нейронні зв’язки вже постійно працюють над запитанням, що я можу ще зробити,
щоб люди, які зараз сидять, які були вбиті, які в лікарнях і навіть політв'язні наші,
претенденти на пост президента республіки Білорусь, які зараз сидять,
вони вже довго сидять...
Що там з ними роблять, нікому не відомо. І що я можу зробити, щоб цього не було.
Дуже багато раніше аполітичних білорусів, зокрема й тих, які живуть за кордоном,
стали з напругою стежити за політичним життям своєї батьківщини
і брати в ньому посильну участь:
виходити на мітинги солідарності, проводити екзитполи біля виборчих дільниць.
За словами наукової співробітниці університету Бремена Ольги Дриндової,
пояснити це можна трьома причинами.
По-перше, у білоруській політиці з'явилися нові обличчя, з якими пов'язані надії на зміни.
По-друге, консолідація почалася ще під час кризи через коронавірус...
І третій фактор - це ті абсолютно безпрецедентні репресії вже до виборів.
Тобто зазвичай у Білорусі репресії такого масштабу відбуваються після виборів.
А те, що ми спостерігали, було вже за місяць, за два,
і просто білоруси не хотіли цього терпіти.
Уже кілька днів жителі Кельна Юлія Воробйова і Павло Перевозчиков пильно стежать за тим,
що відбувається у Білорусі. Минулими вихідними ця пара, яка переїхала до Німеччини
з Гомеля, вирішила поєднати канікули у Баварії і голосування в консульстві Республіки Білорусь у Мюнхені.
Почали всі ці події розгортатися - і ми зрозуміли, що потрібно з'їздити
хоч якось проявити свою громадянську позицію, тому що багато років ми її ігнорували.
Думали, що шансів і варіантів немає.
Ну, не ігнорували...
Швидше, бойкотували, а не ігнорували.
Білоруси, які живуть у країнах Європи, не обмежуються акціями солідарності
та збором коштів для постраждалих під час протестів.
Вони звертаються безпосередньо до влади європейських країн і структур Євросоюзу
та закликають вжити заходів проти режиму Лукашенка.
Однак поки реакція ЄС їм здається недостатньою.
Засудження - це одне. На мій погляд, мають бути персональні санкції проти чинного...
нечинного, на мій погляд, президента. Санкції мають бути спрямовані в тому числі на людей,
які фальсифікували вибори: це начальники дільниць,
це всі силовики, які брали участь у розгонах.
Павло і Юлія не дуже розраховують на якусь відчутну допомогу і підтримку від Євросоюзу.
І тому сподіваються, що децентралізовані мирні акції протесту в Білорусі продовжаться
і врешті-решт принесуть свої плоди.